hey guys it's gary uh time to do another
gv.com
there's a lot of things that go on when
you build a business and when you're
making business decisions
but rowdy piper and i are scared of one
thing more than
any other and that's a very interesting
part
of your body and your dna when you're
doing business and that's called
emotion emotion is scary
when you make emotional decisions when
in business
you are in big trouble because
and i know this is not that profound but
getting into these debates lately about
journalism where it's going or uh
anything you know especially journalism
and when you start saying things like oh
the new york times in trouble
you know that people are making
emotional political decisions people are
debating
if it's a viable business based on their
politics
it's silliness and in a day and age
where the internet the 14 year old
internet
that we've all underestimated so much is
growing up becoming a teenager
and really starting to bash all
traditional media it is just funny to me
when i see ceos of major companies
that have a lot to lose or employees of
those industries
making emotional decisions instead of
adjusting
looking at the picture and moving their
careers in different opportunities
and that's something that a lot of
people have to pay attention to
when you make emotional decisions
whether it's employees buying
advertising
i owe it the jets used to be so smart
they would hit me up all the time to buy
advertising
and though i love them more than life no
emotion when it comes to business
i fired a best friend that worked for
wine library at one point
i didn't hire friends that wanted to
work for wine library at some points
i think it's just massively important
for anybody that's running a business
to make sure emotion is completely
sucked out when making decisions
and when you're debating make sure
you're coming from a point
make sure you know you're debating i
mean i'm not debating run on sentences
you with a little bit of me maybe we're
changing the business world